Welcome to the James River Church podcast.
You're about to hear another inspirational message from Pastor John Lindell.
Lead pastor at James River Church.
It's our prayer that this message is an encouragement and blessing to your life.
Well, this morning, if you have your Bible signed by you to turn with me to the book of James, where we're in a series on the book that we've entitled, The Essentials.
Because what James' concern is for us is that you and I would have
a vibrant faith, that we would have a faith that has a vitality and a strength to it.
One of the ways we have that is when you and I are doing what the word says to do.
One of the things that diminishes faith and the strength of our faith is when we become selective in our obedience to Christ.
I'll do this, but I'm not going to do that.
So what James does is James wants us to evaluate ourselves.
And he gives us a series of tests by which we can do that.
The first test we saw was the test of trials.
How you and I go through trials has a lot to do with where we're at in terms of our service of God.
And then we looked at temptation and James gives one of the best studies of temptation in all of God's word.
The next test was how you and I respond to the word of God.
Today the test is how you and I approach prejudice and partiality.
So today the title of the message is the sin of prejudice and partiality.
Anyone who has observed American society
knows that we are a society that has been torn apart by racial strife.
And every now and then, something happens that again causes people to rise up and the racial tensions flare.
And I would suggest that in some ways, in the last 10 years, it has become even more pronounced.
So let me just say this at the start of this message.
If anyone feels the urge to label me as woke or as being politically correct in giving a message like this, that would not only be ignorant, it would be untrue.
I would add this, I will never let the threat of a label
Keep me from preaching biblical truth.
In 1996, on the heels of the O.J.
Simpson trial and verdict, racial tensions were flaring, and I did a message back at the old building on race and prejudice.
Toward the end of the message is really one of the most memorable moments in my 35 years at James River.
Toward the end of the message I heard sobbing coming from a part of the auditorium and I couldn't be sure where it was coming from but eventually kind of zeroed in on that.
I walked off the platform and walked toward it and it was an African American man who got out of his seat and hugged me and we hugged one another and he sobbed almost
uncontrollably.
As some of you know, Springfield, Missouri and Southwest Missouri has a very sad history concerning racial prejudice, which explains the lack of diversity in the area.
I don't know what you've ever wondered, but when you look at the area
and you have Kansas City with diversity, and you have St. Louis with diversity, and you have Memphis with diversity, and you have Little Rock with diversity, and you have Tulsa with diversity, and then all of a sudden you come to Southwest Missouri, and it's easily 90 to 95% Caucasian across all of the area.
Anybody who moves here from the outside almost always looks around and says, where's everybody else?
I mean, you just have this sense
that there is a huge vacuum when it comes to diversity.
And I want to suggest to you that that is rooted in the history of this area.
On Friday, April 13, 1906, a white couple told police they were attacked by two masked black men
and that the woman was raped.
This was in Springfield.
Fred Coker, age 21, and Horace Duncan, 20, were accused of the rape and jailed, although their employer, a white man, told police that they were at work at the time of the attack and well beyond that time, meaning these two black men could not have committed the crimes.
Another black man by the name of William Allen, age 25, was also jailed, having been falsely accused of killing a white man.
The man who actually had committed the murder had escaped in the events that I will describe following.
On Saturday evening, or Saturday night, excuse me, before Easter Sunday, a mob of over 1,000 men stormed the jail and the adjoining house of Sheriff Everett Horner.
The city and the county law enforcement turned
a blind eye, causing the pastor of the first congregational church to later say, quote, we might as well have had a jellyfish for a sheriff and a set of ragdolls for police.
The mob took Fred Coker and Horace Duncan to the square and hung them from the light tower.
Unsatisfied, the mob returned to the jail, and since the cell door would not open, they took a sledgehammer
And after two hours of pounding on the cell door, they were able to break the cell door open.
The mob then took William Allen to the square and hung him along with the two other men.
Following the hanging, at about three in the morning, they threw kerosene on all three men, burned their bodies, and then went to church for Easter services.
enterprising businessmen took pictures capturing the still rising smoke and the Easter sight seers.
Many on their way to church are coming from church who stopped to pick up little pieces of cloth as souvenirs from the men's bodies and from the ashes.
While other entrepreneurs sold medals, one read, quote, Easter offering, end quote.
that Easter Sunday afternoon, groups of men gathered on the square and talked of burning the black sections of the city.
It was not an idle threat.
Five years earlier, in Pierce City, Missouri, which is just southwest of Springfield, a lynch mob hung two young black men, shot an elderly man and set fire to all the black houses, incinerating an elderly disabled man
who could not get out of his house in time.
They then broke into the militia headquarters, stole guns, and chased every remaining black person out of Pierce City.
Three years prior to the Springfield incident, in Joplin, Missouri, in 1903, a mob of several thousand white people battered down the wall of the city jail and forcibly removed a 20-year-old black man by the name of Thomas Gilliard,
and lynched him in broad daylight, hanging him from a telephone pole to blocks from the jail.
Although Mr. Gilliard maintained his innocence, local officials and law enforcement failed to use force to repel the mob.
Unsatisfied with the killing of Mr. Gilliard, the mob did the following.
They demanded a local man named Hickory Bill, who was in jail for attacking a black person to
be released, which the city officials promptly did.
The white mob then gathered on Main Street, drove all of the black people from downtown into a segregated black district north of Joplin, and then proceeded to launch an attack on that community by robbing and then burning the homes, and then shooting and stoning any black person they saw.
They even blocked the local fire department
from extinguishing the flames.
The mob then turned to another black district south of the town and found that the black residents had already fled out of fear, so the mob burned their homes too.
It is unknown how many black people were killed in the violence on that day.
In the aftermath of the Springfield lynchings, 18 men were indicted for the murders, but only one man was charged
and he was acquitted.
In 1906, a number of African-American residents living in Springfield was approximately 2,300 people, which was 15% of the city's population.
Among them were doctors, lawyers, business owners, and other educated professionals.
Following the lynching, most of them moved out of Springfield
and the African-American population in Springfield fell to 2%.
Sadly, the result of these despicable injustices is still reflected in the demographics of Southwest Missouri.
Currently, black or African-American is living in Springfield account for 4.5% of the population, and in Joplin, Missouri,
African Americans account for 3.2% of the total population.
Bill McCartney, the former head coach of the Colorado Buffaloes and the founder of Promise Keepers, wrote this, Daniel pleaded with the Lord in prayer and fasting because he understood that Jerusalem would suffer desolation for 70 years for the sins of his generation
and the generations of his forefathers.
Most Americans live in a now only mentality, but the historic cultures of the world represent a radical alternative to this thinking and help us understand the biblical principle of generational sin.
The Chinese, for example, tend to take a long look at their history.
They see their own lives integrally linked to their national ethnic
history spanning millennia.
Not only do we tend to be ignorant of the biblical principle of generational sin involved here, but we also just don't like it.
To our highly individualistic way of thinking, it doesn't seem fair.
But God is not bound by our sense of fairness, and the biblical principle stands.
Less than a century and a half ago, the forefathers of our contemporary black brothers and sisters
were being treated as subhuman animals, property to be chained and whipped, bought and sold by many of our white forefathers.
Have we in the church ever repented of that sin in any significant extent?
No, we have not.
We have stood against a lot of other social evils, but we have not stood against racism and called it what it is, sin.
We've been divided by racism,
staying silent, acting with at best only token resistance.
We should feel conviction deep in our souls for this sin.
The damage is incalculable.
The toll is immeasurable.
We should drop to our knees before God Almighty in repentance.
As we come to James chapter 2, the first 13 verses, the subject is prejudice and partiality.
What James is going to do is he's going to show us that the problem with him is that they clash with God's character, they break God's commands, and they so engulf people's thinking that they forget about God's coming judgment.
I want you to see three things as we look at this passage.
First of all, prejudice and partiality ignore God's character.
The very first thing that James does is he points to God's character in James chapter two and verse one, my brothers show no partiality.
As you hold to the faith in our Lord Jesus Christ, the Lord of glory.
What he's saying essentially is that
prejudice and partiality is inconsistent with our faith.
It's inconsistent with who God is.
When we think of God often, we think of his attributes of holiness, justice, righteousness, love, power, knowledge, sovereignty, grace, mercy, eternality, all of these things we could name.
But there is one attribute of God that we don't often talk about, and yet it is frequently mentioned in Scripture, and that is the attribute of impartiality.
God is absolutely, totally impartial when it comes to dealing with people.
We have a tendency when we look at people to categorize people or to respond to them based on their looks, their job, their social status.
But the fact of the matter is, all of those things are not issues with God.
He is impartial.
When he looks at those things,
It's not that he doesn't care about those things, but those things don't weigh into his evaluation of the person who possesses those things.
He's impartial.
In Deuteronomy chapter 10 for the Lord your God is the God of God and the Lord of Lords, the great mighty and awesome God who is not partial.
is very, very interesting to me that when Moses wants to say that he's the Lord of lords, he's the God of gods, he could name any number of attributes, and yet the one he chooses is God is not partial.
He's not a respecter of persons.
looks at people and evaluates them as they actually are.
Really, only he can do that, but he is not swayed by the external.
God's impartiality can be seen in two areas.
He's impartial when it comes to salvation.
Look at it in Acts chapter 10 and verse 34.
Peter opened his mouth and said, truly understand that God shows no partiality.
But in every nation, anyone who fears him and does what is right is acceptable to him.
God has no favorites.
Whosoever will may come.
The ground at the foot of the cross is level.
Anyone of any color, any ethnicity, any race can come to know Jesus Christ because God is impartial.
Second,
God is not partial when it comes to judgment.
Romans chapter 2 verse 9, there will be tribulation and distress for every human being who does evil, the Jew first and also the Greek.
But glory and honor and peace for everyone who does good, the Jew first and also the Greek.
For God shows no partiality.
It's not going to go easier on Jewish people than it is.
Gentiles is not going to go easier on black people than it is whites.
Colossians chapter 3 verse 25, for the wrongdoer will be paid back for the wrong he is done and there is no partiality.
God is not prejudice, he is not partial, he has no favorites, he estimates and evaluates a person purely on the basis of their heart.
For Samuel chapter 16, for the Lord sees not as man sees, man looks on the outward appearance, but the Lord looks on the heart.
This is how God evaluates people.
This is his character.
And so when Paul says, be imitators of God, that's how you and I are to be.
We're not to look at the external.
And while we can't see a heart, we can hear a heart out of the abundance of the heart the mouth speaks.
We can't see a heart.
We can watch what a person's actions are.
It tells us where their heart is.
We can't see a person's heart.
We can watch where they put their money.
Because where your treasure is, there will be a heartbeat also.
It tells us something about people.
And not that it is ours to judge.
In fact, God says it's not our place by and large.
Second, I want you to notice,
Prejudice and partiality ignore God's command.
Chapter two, verse one, my brothers show no partiality.
That's a command.
In the new living translation, it says, my dear brothers and sisters, how can you claim to have faith in our glorious Lord Jesus Christ if you favor some people over others?
How can you claim to be a Christian and to have faith in Jesus
if you are partial or prejudice toward people.
It's absolutely inconsistent with Christianity and with faith.
The two don't go together.
The root word for the word partiality in the Greek, it's the thought of judging someone by their face.
It's idea of making a superficial evaluation of a person's worth based on nothing more than what appears on the outside.
And when we judge someone, evaluate someone, determine someone's worth on the basis of skin color, it's not only ignorant, it's damnable.
Human DNA sequences have now been mapped out and genome studies have been done, and we now know that human DNA sequences are more than 99.9% identical across people.
Which means this, there is only one race of people, the human race.
And the difference in genetics between any two people in the world is 0.1%.
Now think about this, when it comes to what we call racial characteristics, that is skin color, facial features, the difference between any people is 0.012%.
In other words, there's not much difference.
We all come from one set of parents.
In Acts 17, verse 26, he made from one man every nation of mankind to live on the face of the earth, having determined a lot of periods and the boundaries of their dwelling place.
Furthermore, let me just say this.
We all have the same color of skin.
It's called melanin.
Some have more, some have less, but it's the same.
So there shouldn't be any racism or animosity toward one another.
We are all from the same family.
And James is saying, partiality or prejudice is inconsistent with Christianity.
Look at this in chapter two, verse eight.
What's happened is you have an usher.
And the usher is seeding people in the church based on their economic status.
There is a wealthy man that comes in.
The poor man is asked to give up his seat, sit on the floor, which sitting on the floor wasn't bad in that date.
Most people sat on the floor.
But he's saying, I'm gonna let somebody of means have the seat instead of somebody who does not have means.
And so if something as subtle,
as that is viewed as sin as we're going to see.
How much more would somebody's actions or intent or treatment of another person based on their race be even more egregious in terms of sin?
If you really fulfill the royal law according to the scriptures, you shall love your neighbors yourself.
If you can do that, you're doing well.
Here's the thing about loving your neighbors yourself.
It's saying that you're going to do for somebody else, and who's your neighbor, whoever's in need?
It's with the Good Samaritan parable, Thomas.
Luke 10.
So if you're going to love somebody like you love yourself, it means you're going to do for them what you do for yourself.
It is such a high standard.
It's almost unimaginable.
But that's what he calls us to.
My question is, how are you doing when it comes to loving your neighbor?
Do you only love them if they look like you?
Do you only love them if they vote like you?
Do you only love them if they agree with you?
Do you only love them if they make you feel comfortable?
Here's the thing about racism and prejudice is kind of two sides of the same coin.
I would suggest to you racism is the loud part, prejudice is the quiet part.
You don't have to say much to be very prejudice.
Just look the other way.
Don't say anything.
Don't reach out.
Don't make an effort.
Don't stand against injustice.
Don't show hospitality to somebody from a different background than you are who looks different than you.
James says this in verse nine, but if you show partiality, prejudice, you are committing sin.
Now this is an important thing for us to think through.
Because I would suggest to you that in this country, I'm not just saying Southwest Missouri, but I think Southwest Missouri is gonna have to work very hard to overcome the history and it's gonna begin with the repentance and people owning our responsibility.
I didn't grow up here, but I'm responsible, I live here.
You may have grown up.
somewhere else, you might have grown up in another country, but you live here, now it's your problem.
We have a responsibility to acknowledge the sins of our forebearers.
We have a responsibility to repent over those sins.
Daniel didn't commit sins, but here he is hundreds of miles away repenting over the sins of his fathers and forefathers and doing it, and God acknowledges that as right, and that is what brings about a change in the situation.
We have a responsibility in how we think about things, and especially how we treat people.
And if we show partiality, we're committing sin, and we are convicted as lawbreakers, literally it's your working sin, you're actually working it, you're actually in the process of working sin, and you have been adjudicated as guilty, it's a legal term.
Verse 10, he goes on to say this, for whoever keeps the whole law that fails in one point has become accountable for all of it.
For he who said, do not commit adultery also said, do not murder, but if you do not commit adultery, but do murder, you become a transgressor of the law.
You say, I don't get it.
Why does breaking one law mean I've broken all of it?
Well, let's just say this for starters.
How many sins does it take to send you to hell?
One.
But in the context of this, what we have to understand is the Bible isn't made up of a bunch of individual commands thought up by different people through the millennia.
The Bible is breathed by the Spirit of God
Men were moved by the Holy Spirit to write it down.
And what we have in the Bible is the counsel of God and the reflection of the will of God.
So if I violate one command, I'm violating God's law, his commands, and his standard, and that makes me guilty.
So God's command is don't show partiality.
And if you do, you have violated this command and you become a transgressor.
And if this is in regard to an usher who sets one person in one place and one person in another place, though they maybe don't even know what's happening, if something like that makes them a lawbreaker.
And the language behind it is so serious, how much more would prejudice?
Number three, I want you to notice this prejudice and partiality, ignore God's coming judgment.
We'll all give an account.
In 2 Corinthians chapter five, in verse 10, we looked at it last week for we must all appear before the judgment seat of Christ.
This is believers.
That each one may receive what is due him for the things done well in the body, whether good or bad.
And the one whose eyes burned with fire is gonna evaluate not only what we said,
But what we did, what we joked about, what we made fun of, and also what we thought, our thoughts will be laid bare before the Lord Jesus Christ.
And that ought to be so very sobering to each one of us that it would cause us to be very careful not only what we say, but even what we
think, for as a man thinks in his heart, so is he.
That's why James says in James chapter two and verse 12, so speak and so act as those who are going to be judged under the law of liberty.
It's like as you're speaking, as you're acting, constantly be realizing that you will be judged based on the things you say
and the things you do.
Honestly, if that was our guide, there's a lot of things we would never say.
Or post, or write, or think.
James says this in verse 13, there will be no mercy for those who have not shown mercy to others.
Wow.
Oh, see, he's not talking to non-Christians.
We're talking to Christians here.
So if prejudice and partiality have been a part of how you roll, then you have to realize that there is an accountability that you will have before God that will be severe.
We have to realize that.
If you're merciful, there's evidence of Christ's work in your heart.
If you're careful about what you say, what you think, mercy will triumph over judgment.
Now, in the remaining few moments, what I'd like to do is I'd like to give you a few steps in responding to racism.
Number one, call prejudice what it is.
It's sin.
But if you show partiality,
You are committing sin.
If you show prejudice, you're committing sin.
When a person is prejudice, it's not just a cultural misunderstanding.
It's not just the way you were raised.
It's not just you being funny and joking around.
It's not your personality.
It's sin.
And let's be clear why people have said things about
Latinos and black people in Asians and black people have said things about white people and Latinos and Asians and Asians have said things about black people and Latinos and white people.
Everybody's saying everything about everybody else.
What's so crazy about that is that for most people, whatever color they are, they think that's the best, which makes no sense at all.
And whatever form you have prejudice, it's sin.
Number two, that means we have to repent and turn from racism in our past or in our present.
Isn't that how we handle all sin?
And not only should we repent from our own personal sin, but there should be something inside us that calls out for the sin of the nation
just as we would in the case of any sin that has been committed on a wholesale basis in our country.
Much of what we're living with today and the way of problems in our nation's cities can be directly attributable to God's judgment on a nation that for decades has been incredibly prejudice.
I know people don't
like to hear that.
My thinking is this, and the next thing we're gonna talk about is relationships.
If you just bring that up, reach out to people who don't look like you and build real relationships.
When somebody doesn't think prejudice is that big a deal, here's what it tells me, you have no friends of color if you're white.
Because once you have friends of color, you see things very different because you will know them well enough to know what's happening in their world.
When I think of the different people of color who have stood in this pulpit, without exception, they've all told me what life's like for them.
And for their children, it's very difficult.
You see, a lot of times we're not thinking about the things that people of color have to deal with
especially in a society like ours.
I can tell you this, I have tried many, many times to hire African Americans on our staff.
It's very hard.
The reason why is because of the lack of diversity is certainly one thing, but the second thing is they know what it's gonna be like.
Other friends have told how, you know, they just have to tell their kids.
Listen, and I mean, these are personalities, if I named them, many of them have been in my own pulpit.
We have to tell our kids, make sure you keep your hands out of your pocket, you go in the store, get that hood off.
It's the things white people don't think about.
And I'm just saying that there can be a, you know, prejudice is quiet.
There's some, and for you, you don't like Martin Luther King holiday.
You roll your eyeballs.
I don't agree with that.
Well, listen, for a large segment of our population, that holiday represents the progress that's been made in attaining civil rights that have helped their community.
And I mean, I'm thinking in my own mind, listen, the Bible says we should weep with those who weep, and we should rejoice with those who rejoice.
And if they're rejoicing, I'm rejoicing.
If they're weeping, I'm weeping.
So you get a holiday.
Good grief, that's a good thing, right?
Let's have a holiday, right?
Well, working really hard.
I like a holiday.
You know what I'm saying?
But some of you, it greats on you, and I'm telling you, there's only one reason.
And you have to think this through because racism and prejudice are insidious.
And we could take it with, we could take it with
the Latinos, we can take it, and you know, there's just a lot of things that are there that people don't think about.
There was a study done, and it was done by, I read several studies, I read one by Intuit, I read one by Business Journal, but there was a study that was done of 1.8 million people, and it followed people of different races, so you had the Latinos, you had the African-Americans, you had whites and you had Asians, and if you got a bachelor
degree and you were all doing the same job, what was your pay scale?
A Latino made $20,000 less than a white person.
A black made $10,000 less than a white person and an Asian made $10,000 more than a white person.
And then it went on and it showed how
you know, whether you're in business, the cost of doing business or the number of loans, if you're a black, if you're a black applying for a loan for a business, you'll be turned down 50%, 57% of the time.
If you're white, it'll be about 30% of the time.
I'm just simply saying that some of these things are not right.
It's not right.
And I simply want us as a church, if there's one place to ground ought to be level,
There's one place where everybody ought to be welcome.
If there's one place where we're for everybody, it ought to be the church.
That's what the church should be.
A place where we can all celebrate one another and cheer one another and encourage one another and stand with one another.
And if somebody's hurting, we're hurting it.
If somebody's happy, we're happy.
And the world may be divided, but the church ought to be united.
Thank you for that.
You may be seated for just a moment.
So how do we do this?
So back to the relationship thing.
You see, it's when you're sharing a meal, it's when you're beyond like, hey, how you doing?
You know, all of those things have their place, but it's when you actually begin to get to know one another enough that they feel comfortable sharing their heart.
That's when you're gonna hear what life's like.
And honestly,
That's when you're really going to be able to encourage somebody.
Number four, let's see racism for what it is.
It's an attack at the enemy.
It is so demonic.
What has happened in this country?
It's a demonic problem.
Satan is the sower of racial prejudice.
He's the one who causes people to hate one another.
He's the one who gets us to try to treat one another with prejudice and partiality.
Let's see it for what it is.
Let's call it out.
Let's say this is a demonic problem that the Church of the Living God says, enough is enough, and we're not gonna take it anymore.
We rebuke you, Satan.
And finally ask the Holy Spirit.
to restrain your instincts and emotions.
You know, at the natural, you know, our humanities, our humanity, it's fallen.
It's fleshly.
So that's why you and I have to have the Holy Spirit working in us to redeem us and renew us and to help us.
Do you know Peter, the apostle, had prejudice?
Watch what happens.
The Holy Spirit comes to him, works him over, and it happens in the afternoon, changes his heart.
And he said to them, you yourselves know how unlawful it is for a Jew to associate with or to visit anyone of another nation, but God has shown me.
I should not call any person common or unclean.
God has shown me that's wrong.
And then watch this, watch what happened.
So Peter opened his mouth and he said, truly I understand God shows no partiality, but in every nation, anyone who fears him and does what is right is acceptable to him.
Peter says, I learned that partiality is wrong.
God learned prejudice is wrong.
And the Holy Spirit's the one who showed him.
We all need to pray this prayer.
Here it is.
God, help me to see people.
and the love people like you see people and like you love people.
I want to encourage you, pray that prayer with you.
God, help us to see people and love people like you see people and love people.
God, may we be agents of courage
agents of love, agents of change.
Lord, in this society and where once there was heard in sorrow and pain, may there be healing and life.
Lord, may there be a grace from God and the power of the Holy Spirit that would level the ground at the foot of the cross, that men and women of every race, of every background might come to know you, might come to love you, might come to worship you,
And oh, God, may we be like you.
May we not judge by outward appearances, but Lord, in our heart, may we love each and every person knowing they were made in the image of God.
May we be outraged at prejudice, and Lord, may we work to make things right in the name of Jesus.
Oh, God, may we as a church be mighty and powerful.
May we be sold in life in our generation.
Father, we thank You for it in Jesus' name.